♪ Well tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
♪ And the party don't stop
because it keeps on going ♪
♪ Non-stop gonna
party all night ♪
♪ Gonna keep this party going
'cause the party won't stop ♪
(beat boxing theme music)
(party horn blowing)
(knocking on door)
- [Jordan] Whoop, here
we go, we got more.
- Hey!
- What's up Ted and Annette!
Come on in.
Yes!
- Alright.
- Fangs for coming.
(both laugh)
Have a bloody good time.
Awesome.
Oh!
- He-hee!
- Here he is. What's up, Noah?
- Michael Jackson.
- Woo!
He-hee.
- Oh, there it is.
- He-hee!
- Yeah, that's what he does.
- That's Michael Jackson.
- He-hee!
- All right.
- He-heee...
- Great.
- Ow!
- Nice.
- Oh! Sham!
- Oh there we go.
- Sham!
- There we go.
- All right.
Three is the charm.
- Shamone!
- Four.
- All right, well-
- Annie, are you okay?
- Oh, he's leaning!
He's leaning!
- Are you okay, Annie?
- All right, are you okay?
- Annie, are you okay, Annie?
You've been touched
by a smooth criminal.
- Very nice.
Oh!
- Shamone!
- More kicks.
- Closer.
Close to your face.
- You almost-
You're really-
- Shamone!
- No more "Shamone!"
You wanna come inside?
(footsteps thudding)
That's annoying.
That is very an-
Stop! Stop!
Just don't do it anymore!
Great.
- Shamone!
- You keep doing the "Shamone".
That's-
- Where the children at?
He-hee!
- "Where are the children at?"
That's some bad taste.
This isn't-
Don't even know what that is.
- "Thriller" eyes.
Shamone!
- What are you doing?
(Noah vocalizing)
- No, you're cut
off of "Shamones".
- Oh, okay.
(hand slaps)
- He doesn't slap
his ass like that,
so I don't know what-
Okay.
- Nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, nah, nah!
Nah, nah!
- He doesn't-
I've never seen him hit his ass-
Hey!
- Ohh!
- Hey.
(Noah vocalizing)
Can we just.
(Noah continues vocalizing)
- Hey stop! Stop it!
Stop it!
(Noah continues vocalizing)
- The (beep) costume's awful!
The impression is
stupid and played out.
Everybody and their
mother was Michael Jackson
three years ago when he died!
- He died?
- Oh...
- Wait, wait, wait.
He died?
- Oh Noah...
Oh Noah.
- Boo-hoo.
- What?
Now, wait, wait a second.
- Don't sad moonwalk away...
(Noah vocalizing)
Happy Halloween.
- And now we have
a special treat.
Hold on to your yarmulkes, okay.
"From east to west, you
know they're the best.
Getting you in the zone
for your milestone."
Isn't that cute?
"Please welcome Gefilta
Fresh and Dr. Dreidel!"
(upbeat music)
- What's up temple batters!
- Y'all,
is there a Daniel
Rosenblum in the hizzouse?
- Oh yeah!
- What's up my man?
Yeah all right!
(traditional Jewish
music remixed)
- When you see black
people at a bar mitzvah,
it's very exciting.
It's like a scary ride
and the kids just love it
- Right now we are the
number one bar/bat mitzvah
party motivators in
all of Nassau County.
- I mean, you got
the Bat Mizzles,
Oys to Men,
you know, all of them coming
through like a vilde chaye,
with the recycled dreads.
- And I mean, the
chutzpah of these guys.
With their fakakta shtick,
it's a real shanda on
what it's supposed to be.
- A simcha, you know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's supposed to be a simcha.
- Just really can't put a price
on the look on your child's face
when they see a black
person for the first time.
(air cannon fires)
- [All] Ohh!
- Oh, it's just magical. Really.
Is he getting back up or what?
- We are not technically chosen.
- [Gefilta Fresh] We're
chosen by the chosen.
- That's son bitch is kind
of better than being the,
just the chosen
- That's right.
It's less responsibility.
- Jews are like black people,
but we were black people
before there were black people.
Although I guess
that's not true.
They were just in a different-
(air cannon fires)
Part of the world-
They're all black people,
coming to get me! Help!
(traditional Jewish
music remixed)
(all applause)
- I find it spiritually
intoxicating.
We find it culturally
fascinating.
And we find it
monetarily exhilarating.
- When we say Sarah,
you say Schwartzman.
- Sarah!
- Schwartzman!
- Yeah!
- I mean, the fact that
we're willing to put forth
the extra time is
what sets us apart.
- [Gefilta Fresh] I mean,
how often is a 13 year old
gonna hear they're own name?
- We learn that
name. We rehearse it.
- Go Daniel! Go Daniel!
Go Daniel! Go Daniel!
Judaism can be a
very somber religion.
- That's right, you know,
something we learned
along the way
is that the word "ghetto"
means something very
different to these people
- To tell you the truth,
I was a little nervous
about the whole thing.
No, not because they were black,
but because you
never really know
what those kind of
people are gonna do.
- [Dr. Dreidel] If we can
add some fun, some life,
some color to a
Jewish person's life
when they're still young-
- [Gefilta Fresh]
They might not grow up
and run away from black
people when they see 'em.
- [Dr. Dreidel] Maybe they won't
- Or-
- Fire people so willy nilly.
When they're older.
(energetic rock music)
- We provide a service
to these people.
- Yeah!
- We motivate parties.
- That's what we do.
- That's what we do.,
we motivate parties.
(energetic rock music continues)
- All right, everybody focus up.
Look, this party
tonight could be a model
for the way that the
world should work.
And I just wanna say,
I'm totally stoked
to the max about it.
All right? You
guys feeling good?
- Yeah!
- Let's do it!
- Dennis, what are
you shooting video?
- Yeah, man.
- All right,
well be careful with that, I
might run for office someday.
(all laugh)
Now, trust me,
I think that this party can be
the most inspirational party
this campus has ever seen.
Is that coming to me?
Just grab that.
(joint puffing)
That's some righteous bud.
Some righteous bud we
got going on there.
We need some bodacious
jock babes coming in.
We need some hot
punk rock babes.
I don't care where
they come from,
the most important thing,
it's imperative that
we have a diversity
in the pussy department.
Intercepted.
Don't sleep on Barry-O,
don't ever sleep on Barry-O.
Whoo!
That is some major doobage.
(indistinct chattering)
- Hey!
- Apartheid is totally gnarly.
It's a gnarly institution.
Where is he, Dennis? Dennis?
Come over here,
get this, get this.
Okay.
We, we gotta have a system in
place to get everybody weed.
All right?
So just watch-
This is how you're
gonna do it, all right.
This, this is-
I'm really (beep) frosty
right now, by the way.
This is your
constitution, all right?
It's just a piece of paper,
we gotta keep its integrity,
'cause it's gonna hold
everything together.
This right here, this is us.
This is the American people.
We're special, we're magic.
Hello? Yay!
We all live in here.
All right, the most
important thing
is that we don't
get too far apart.
Me and you, we,
we gotta be close!
That's that's the magic
of America, is love.
Otherwise we're gonna
get air bubbles in there,
it's gonna start
canoeing and everything,
we don't want that, all right?
You get that?
Well look, I'm way ahead of
you, but I'm already done.
Boom, fireworks, 4th of July.
That's for you.
We want like 10 of these.
Oh my God I'm so
(beep) wasted! (laughs)
I'm so (beep) high!
Oh (beep) what was I saying?
- To the man of the hour.
(glasses chink)
- Guys?
Best bachelor party ever!
(all cheer)
- Oh yeah.
- Wooh!
- That's the stuff.
- I can still do it.
- All right! Fellas!
What do you say,
we get a stripper!
- [All] Yes!
- Trey, I told you,
man, no strippers.
- Is this a bachelor
party or isn't it?
- I'm your best man,
there's no way I'm
gonna let you puss out
on your own bachelor party.
We gettin the stripper, and
we gonna connect the dots.
- Yes!
- Connect the dots?
- Yeah! Tinker-toy it, man!
You're behind her,
and then we all...
Bup, bup, bup, bup.
We go to town!
- Yeah!
- To town!
- Wait, wait, hold on.
Wait, wait, what's, what's
"bup, bup, bup, bup"?
- Dude, you know, you know
you're up front, then...
Bup, bup, bup, bup, game on!
- So hold up, hold
up, hold up, hold up.
No, what's the "bup,
bup, bup, bup"?
- Yeah yeah, what is that?
- Guys!
This is Tommy's last
night of freedom!
- Yeah, what's "bup,
bup, bup, bup" though?
- You know?
Bup, bup, bup, bup!
- Okay, okay when you say,
"bup, bup, bup, bup",
are we, what are we, are we all-
- Linked up! Yeah!
Baby elephant walk! Woo!
- Okay. Okay.
Okay. Are, are are
you saying that,
that we would, we would
all be (beep) each other?
- (laughs) You don't
understand what I'm-
Oh dude!
Okay. Look.
Here it is okay.
You're (beep) a girl, right?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Then....
We bup, bup, bup, bup-
- That's it right there.
- Right there.
- Yeah. Yeah.
What the (beep)
I'm not doing that!
- You guys!
Tommy's about to walk the
plank of marriage, all right?
This is our last chance!
- Last chance for what?
I'm not gonna (beep) a guy.
- Yeah!
- No dude!
We'd all be (beep) the girl!
- Oh!
- Okay, yeah.
- Together, bup, bup, bup, bup.
- [All] No!
- You see, but right there
Trey, that's the weird part.
The "bup, bup, bup, bup"
- Okay. I get it, I get it.
You don't wanna be disrespectful
to women, I get that.
- That's not really the issue.
- Forget the girl.
Armenian conveyor belt, just
the groom and his groomsman,
bup, bup, bup, bup.
- [All] No!
- You kept the part
that nobody wants!
The "bup, bup, bup, bup"!
- Yeah I definitely don't wanna
have sex with any of you guys!
- Yeah you're killing my buzz!
- Guys! What the (beep) man!
This is supposed to be
Tommy's last big celebration,
no judgment.
- Judgment is not what
is keeping us from
(beep) each other!
Geez, forget it Trey!
- No, I'm saying guys, if
you listen, to my words...
Tommy's in here
(beep) the stripper,
we're in the other room!
Bup, bup, bup, bup.
- [All] No!
- Bup, bup, bup, bup!
- Nobody wants "bup,
bup, bup, bup"!
- Okay! No bup,
bup, bup, bup, okay!
No bup, bup, bup, bup.
You're here (beep) the stripper,
the rest of us are just
jiggy, jiggy, jiggy,
jiggy, jiggy, jiggy-
- [All] No!
- God! You guys are so gay!
(upbeat hip hop music)
♪ Well tonight we're gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
♪ And the party don't
stop because it keeps
on going nonstop ♪
♪ Gonna party all night,
gonna keep this party going ♪
♪ 'Cause the won't party stop ♪
♪ It's been two straight days
and the party still going ♪
♪ Two, three, four,
five, six, seven days ♪
♪ 'Til it's Friday again
and the party keeps going ♪
♪ Party all night 'cause
it's an all-night party ♪
♪ Friday night, 9:00 PM, hop
in the car, call my friends ♪
♪ Drinks in the back,
girls up front ♪
♪ Going to a party,
send them texts ♪
♪ Cellphone rings, iPad,
Facebook, party time ♪
♪ Skintight jeans, Friday
nights, dance, dance, dance ♪
♪ 'Cause tonight we goin'
out and we ain't comin back ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't
stop, it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night, every night,
the party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City,
L.A., Chicago, ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego, ♪
♪ Phoenix, Austin, Fort Worth,
Boston, Memphis, Denver ♪
♪ Portland, Vegas,
Tuscon, Fresno, Akron,
Tampa, Pittsburgh ♪
♪ Newark, Laredo, Lincoln,
Lubbock, Durham, Salem, ♪
♪ Dayton City,
City, City, City ♪
♪ 'Cause tonight we goin'
out and we aint comin back ♪
♪ 'Cause the party won't
stop, it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night, every night,
the party's going down, ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City,
L.A., Chicago, ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego, ♪
♪ Phoenix, Austin, Fort Worth,
Boston, Memphis, Denver ♪
♪ Portland, Vegas,
Tuscon, Fresno, Akron,
Tampa, Pittsburgh ♪
♪ Newark, Laredo, Lincoln,
Lubbock, Durham, Salem, ♪
♪ Dayton City,
City, City, City ♪
♪ City ♪
♪ Yeah we're gonna
keep it going ♪
♪ 'Til the break
of break of dawn ♪
♪ Then we'll just keep partying
all day and all night ♪
♪ Hot girls, music, dancing
in bikinis and headphones ♪
♪ Party, party, party, party,
party, party, party party ♪
(gunshots)
(upbeat hip hop music continues)
♪ So tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
(gentle music)
(indistinct chattering)
- Here is your white wine.
- Thank you.
You are welcome.
- Hey Pete, little,
little thirsty tonight.
- Ah, yeah. Super thirsty.
- Pete, this is Heresa.
Heresa this is Pete.
Heresa just got
back from Africa.
- Oh, Africa.
- Anyways, where was I?
- Oh, the AUC.
- Oh right.
So this conflict is
exactly the reason
the African Union Commission
was put in place to address.
- [Heresa] The Organization
of African Unity
certainly wasn't
gonna do anything.
- Exactly.
And, and if Nkosazana
Dlamini-Zuma wanted
to do anything about Bangui,
she's certainly been quiet about
- The worst part about Bangui is
that no one knows
what's going on.
- Oh no, right?
- Look at right next
door, the South Sudan.
- Here's the thing,
everybody just thinks that
it's like the damn
"Lion King" over there,
you know?
- "Lion King".
- Excuse me?
- It's not "The Lion King".
- Exactly.
- I mean what do people think,
a baboon is gonna hold
a lion cub over a rock,
up to the sun while all
these little animals sing?
- Anyway, something else
I wanted to mention is
they have the manpower, because
AMISOM has 25,000 troops
just sitting there in Somalia.
- It's not a three
animated hyena situation.
That doesn't make any sense.
The bad guy isn't
Scar over there.
- Um yeah, yeah that's right.
It's not like Scar's the bad guy
- Huh. Well, I mean...
You know, the truth is,
no one knows who to blame.
Because in reality, AMISOM
doesn't have that much control.
- They don't.
- Like Simba.
Oh, like Simba.
He had no control over...
He was plucked out from his
home and went on a whole journey
before he came back and was
just in the middle of a war.
Really had nothing
to do with him.
- You know, Pete,
I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts
on the UN's policies
in East Africa.
- Hakuna Matata.
- Unbelievable.
- Yes.
My God that sums
it up perfectly!
There's so much work
still to be done.
- Yes, that's what I was saying.
- [Heresa] It's been going
on for so many years.
- So many years. Circle of life.
- Hmm.
- Exactly. That's
really brilliant.
- I don't know about brilliant.
Let's dial it back.
I'm just a man.
- Okay, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go get some,
some hors d'oeuvres.
- Okay. No need to announce it.
- What are your thoughts
on the Middle East?
- "Aladdin".
- Hmm.
(gentle music)
(indistinct chattering)
- Hey, did you see that (beep)?
- That (beep) looked
like Busta Rhymes
and Maya Angelou had a baby!
(all laugh)
- Yeah. That was one
jacked up looking (beep).
(music stops)
(chattering stops)
(gentle whimsical music)
- Uh oh, you just dropped the
N word, but you're not an N.
Lucky for you, there's a way
to avoid these situations.
Introducing the new smartphone
application, "The Negraph".
Finally, a technology
specifically designed
to help you determine
whether or not
you can drop the N bomb.
- I can say it!
- [All] We can all say it!
- Not in this lifetime.
- [Spokesman] To see
your Negraph, just
into your name, age
and color of your skin,
or, just the color of your skin.
- I've got The Negraph
on my phone, and my iPad.
My phone says I
can't ever say it,
My iPad says I can't
ever say it, but bigger!
- [Spokesman] The Negraph.
Can you say the N word?
- (laughs) I can say
(beep) all day long!
- [All] (beep)
- No.
I'd like to, but it
says right here...
- [Spokesman] The Negraph.
(upbeat theme music)
♪ All I want is ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪